[Music]
hello my name is Lama del Volcan I work
on Google kubernetes engine so my job is
to basically make Korea's engine easier
to understand to developers and defend
developers choices within Google
previously I worked at Microsoft I went
in several kubernetes related open
source projects and my name is Yoshi
this is my third talk in this next so
I'm glad I'm making it I work on multi
I'm a product manager and kubernetes
engine and I work on multi-tenancy
including I just gave a speech advisor
sandbox and the hardware accelerator
like a machine learning workloads like
in using GPU and cloud type you all
include renews engine ok
so let's jump into the topic so we're
gonna cover a multi-tenancy any
practical thing in the communities
engine Corona T's I've been kind of
talking is I think everyone knows this
because you know even Aquino Karina's
was mentioned so many times it's
everywhere and quite pervasive as a
consequence I think a large teams large
organizations have also adopted
kubernetes and also kubernetes engine as
a result just great and then when large
teams and large you know those large
runners and come to us and okay I want
to discrimination cool and people can
ask a common kind of question that so
I'm a large organization have multiple
teams and with multiple requirements how
can we actually use crew renée's engine
and cluster with multiple teams this is
actually very very kind of a complex you
know question because answering to you
know how you do it there are so many
actually ways and honestly we thought
you know because there's so many ways we
actually we actually wanted to ask your
question so we created a link here
educator page like multi-tenancy you'll
see the questions I'm gonna show this
link later at the talk so no rush but I
think multi-tenancy is something that
it's still emerging economies and we're
trying to grenouille
the criminals engine so we would love to
you know hear your opinion about it you
know what you're doing and what you want
to do and where you want to go as well
to give you what I'm trying to get to
about I know complexity challenges over
you know multi-tenancy this is really
the kind of overview i we're gonna cover
this but these are the kind of areas
that you want to consider before or to
answer to the original question how can
I share GK you know microRNAs engine
among multiple teams in our mid our
rating structure is here to guide you
what you can actually do with the
primitives and the principle that we
have today so back down it thank you or
she alright so we're gonna talk about a
lot of things today it may seem like
we're jumping from topic to topic but
it's gonna be yeah mo heavy so if you're
I'm assuming this is an intermediate
audience for adults familiar with
kubernetes in this talk I want to show
you the practical aspects of
multi-tenancy that you know you can go
home and start using but first we must
define the terminology that we were
gonna use and I want to start with what
is multi-tenancy and in the software
context the multi-tenancy means a single
of software running somewhere and it
serves multiple tenants right you can
simply say any website that your folks
are using probably is a multi tenant
software right so today today's topic is
kubernetes and that's why we're gonna
talk about you know kubernetes as a
multi tenant system and analyze it in
kubernetes terms green's multi-tenancy
is providing isolation and fair resource
sharing between multiple users in a
single cluster this part is important
it's important that it is in a single
cluster so you know we're gonna talk
about like how we're gonna talk now have
the multiple tenants in a single cluster
live happily without stepping out there
stepping on each other's toes and before
we talk about multi-tenancy I first want
to talk about trust and why is it
important so let's go through these
things anyone here completely trusts all
these things in their deployment
pipelines like
they totally trust it I don't think so
so a lot of things that you use to
deploy your software on your software or
build your software but mostly comes
from people that you don't exactly know
right there are papers scientific papers
that I cited on the bottom right you can
take a look at about trusting compilers
and you know verifiable operating
systems is a space on its own and then
you most of you probably use open source
dependencies and your deployment
pipeline is probably Jenkins or
something else and then there are
container runtimes that you folks are
using docker is for instance or
continuty or whatever so do you actually
trust these runtimes
so it's not a binary or anything like
that it's sort of binary choice it's
mostly like the you're probably
somewhere on the spectrum so we classify
these levels of software multi-tenancy
in terms of trusted semi trusted and not
trusted so in the trusted case
everything comes from an out of the
source repository right it's it's
basically pretty much what Google does
and the compiler is trusted the build
system is trusted and even some of the
hardware is trusted but most people are
not they're right most of we most of us
are probably in some place that is semi
trusted we have some trust components
that we rely on and we build our
security models around it so now let's
talk about some of the currents engine
multi-tenancy primitives if you if
you're already doing multi-tenancy today
you're probably segmenting your tenants
in your clusters probably based on
either creating a separate cluster for
each tenant or creating a namespace for
each tenant and both options can be okay
and let's dive into how are they
different in the cluster pertinent case
you're basically creating separate
control planes by control plane I'm in
the kubernetes api anytime you're on
cube CTL gets or something like that you
had two koreas control plane in this
case just because there are separate
clusters you get a separate control
plane and you might actually be getting
separate networks as well if every class
their lives it's on V PC Virtual Private
Network right this can be still useful
if you're separating your clusters
between dev stage at stage and
production
this has some shortcomings such as if
you have a lot of users then you need to
you need tools that manage that yeah
that lets you manage tens and hundreds
of colors of clusters and potentially
this is not a fun job to me yet and you
need to be you know worried about the
fragmentation issues the diverging
configuration that happens in the
cluster and every time someone asks for
you know a runtime you need to go
actually provision that cluster however
namespace is a little bit better than
that and it's mostly because Carini's is
basically providing a lot of policy
objects that are native to criminate his
name spaces so namespace is the building
block that lets us build our multi
tenant infrastructure on kubernetes and
again the pros of this is that anytime
you run a cluster with multiple tenants
any configuration or setting or you know
uptime reliability concerns that you
apply to that cluster is shared by
everyone
anytime you as an add-on extension is
again shared by everyone and in this
case it since you're sharing the control
plane they all benefit from the same
security measures so you know we're
going to talk about a lot of current
security primitives filler' I just
listed some of them here I mainly
categorize them under access control
resource isolation and runtime isolation
and actually we're gonna recategorize
them later so now let's see if Emily ate
some of the common use cases with
kubernetes multi-tenancy like what are
the things that you might be doing so
that you require a multi-tenant
environments on kubernetes we're gonna
look at three different models one of
them is enterprise where you're in a
company and every team is potentially a
tenant and then there is a
software-as-a-service which most users
don't actually see craze but the
infrastructure still runs on kubernetes
and then there's communities of the
service where you're basically accepting
workloads from people that you don't
know so let's focus on the enterprise
enterprise model first in the enterprise
model all users are from the same
company so if anybody is doing something
wrong you can go fire them right in this
case everybody gets its own namespace in
in the diagram you can see up here
there's a cluster admin that potentially
you know has the full permissions on the
cluster and then there are
users you know each emoji here is a
different team and I'm in a team there
is a namespace admin that has little bit
more permissions on that namespace so to
achieve this person as we're looking at
creating cluster roles so again you know
the cluster admin is full admin
namespace admin manages the users in
that namespace and then the user
basically can apply let's say pods and
workloads and load balancers and stuff
like that but they cannot actually edit
the policies so we're gonna come back to
the policies later in this case since
you're probably the oldest or all the
source code is coming from a single code
repository such as your companies you
know source repos maybe the vanilla
container isolation you get with
continually a rocker or something like
that might be okay but if it's not if
you're running components that you don't
trust much you might be considering to
run on something like gee visor for
sandboxing or you can use Linux security
primitives such as you said calm a
farmer is he Linux and stuff like that
so as far as the network isolation is
concerned we're gonna come back to how
the network isolation is done but I
really want to say that each namespace
probably should be able to talk to
anything in that namespace and outside
that namespace you should be worried
about who's calling your applications
right so the next thing I'm gonna touch
is the software is a service model this
is a little bit different basically in
this case the consumer deploys their app
through a custom control plane so the
users of your software is a service does
not know kubernetes much it may be they
are not actually seeing communities at
all in this case after they deploy your
app after they deploy your app they're
basically connecting to the eff directly
so they're not seeing kubernetes in the
middle at all so Carini's is in this
case is an implementation detail so this
is not very interesting to kubernetes
actually an example of this can be you
can imagine wordpress.com anytime you
probably assume that theoretically you
go to wordpress.com you create a blog
and then wordpress.com probably creates
some pods for you and then you directly
talk to your community WordPress admin
page right you don't see kubernetes in
the middle but someone in this case the
cluster admin has access to the create
API
and basically there is a SAS API that is
a trusted client of kubernetes so in
this case the tenant workload can
actually have untrusted pieces and let's
say you have a vert press blog and
you're installing extensions and
extensions are potentially arbitrary
code execution right so in this case you
may require something like sandboxing
again with g-- wiser or some other
runtime and the last model that we're
going to look at is the koreans as a
service model this is you can call this
containers as a services while you know
you're running a hosting company that
you're accepting containers from
everybody what can go wrong in this case
tenants again you know have different
namespaces but in this case they're not
seeing each other at all so you have a
little bit more stronger isolation
requirements than the you know
enterprise or the SAS that we looked at
and the isolation of world we can easily
be achieved with something like Carini's
are back again the network isolation
requires stuff like the sandbox pause
and the multi tenant networking so that
people are actually not stepping on each
other's networking and potentially
significant on each other's networking
so let's let's look a little bit about
like what our leads policy objects and
features that gray's provides to us so
that we can use them in our you know
companies and in our clusters so we
previously talked about these features
like admission control you know our back
and quarters and pod security policies
and bunch of other things so I'm
actually going to let reorganize this
little bit like this the first category
is all through lated and the second
category is going to be the scheduling
related primitives but it actually
doesn't matter it's just sort out we can
easily go through them so let me go
through about let me go through the
author related features first if you're
familiar with kubernetes authentication
authorization and admission this is
basically how the object comes to crazy
API and from the kubernetes api makes it
through HCD which is where it's stored
you don't see the LCD and google create
engine case but basically when you're on
your laptop on or let's say where
there's a pod or a program calling the
kanae's API
first we authorize that request and the
way we authorize that request is either
trooper nazar back or Google Cloud I am
in this case if you're a Google user
with your Gmail or whatever you can be
authorized to GK using the I am
authorizer and if you're not if you're
like you know proven a service account
which is like a you know some identity
that are given to pods then you're
probably going through our back so if
our back allows you then the next thing
is the admission control which we'll
talk about later so let's dig little bit
up in little bit deep into the
authorizer so crazy our bag is letting
you figure out which users or which
groups or which service accounts have
access to which operations and which API
resources on which namespaces so to look
at it to look a little bit deeper into
currents are back so to use cases for
Cooney's are packages you're either
giving people access or you're giving
kubernetes service accounts access and
Korean service accounts are used by the
Pott so there you might have some
controllers trying to access your
Canadians API and these API is the in
this case the API will authorize a
create a service account so four key
concepts in Korea is our back our
cluster role which is you're just
defining a persona a set of permissions
that people can use cluster wide and
there is a name spot namespace scopes
version of that called just role and
they there is a cluster role binding
which lets you bind cluster roles to
users in this case a user could be just
Google users Google Groups you know
cloud I am service accounts or again you
know koreandj service accounts and the
role binding is the namespace version of
that so here's an example our back this
must be the first year what we're seeing
today this is the example cluster roll
an example cluster roll binding and if I
look here I'm defining a namespace
creator persona which is a cross
namespace Kreider cluster roll and then
this namespace Creator can do get let's
watch create delete whatever all these
objects only on the namespace right and
then when I go to the right side
I see the cluster role binding and this
cluster role binding
is assigned to a particular user that's
my email address don't send me spam
please
so it just like I'm adding myself as a
Google user I can as a at a group I can
add a courier service account and so
forth so this is how you give access to
someone to do something on your
communities cause they're using Koreans
are back so I'm gonna jump off our back
and I'm gonna you know talk a little bit
about the GK I am basically how we do
cloud I am this is a little bit
different and it's an alternative to
Korea new brands are back so this is
mostly practical for giving Google users
and Google groups access to all clusters
in your project let's say you
temporarily need to add your colleague
to all clusters as a viewer permission
you can easily use that so we provide
for I am roles today that we curated
admin is like basically you can do
everything Weaver is you can view
everything cluster admin is you can only
manage the clusters lifecycle and create
delete clusters and upgrade them and so
forth the developers is you just look
inside the cluster and edit objects and
create new objects within that cluster
and you don't know about GK at all so
that's just kubernetes related and you
can actually use
I am custom roles to curate your own
more interesting roles again like the
namespace admin I just created using
Koreans are back can also be created
using cloud I am so if you're interested
in project might access this is what
you're looking at so an example of GK I
am I'm sure if you're actually using GK
you probably seen this before you know
you and I am policy binding on the
project you give some user or a group
access and you can specify which role
you want this is the G cloud CLI and
next I'm gonna talk about the admission
controls as anyone here actually wrote
an admission controller before and I'm
curious no wow that's amazing so
admission controllers are primitive in
kubernetes that the requests go through
so anytime you create a pod kubernetes
calls bunch of admission plugins and
each plugin tells kubernetes the spot is
okay or not so anytime it happens
basically anytime you submit a request
that is controlled by a particular
admission plugin your request goes
through a bunch of admission plug-ins
like this so
the admission plugins succeed they
basically run in serial one after
another they go into the HDD and your
pod is created after that so admission
controls are actually compiled into the
Coronas API server so this means you
actually cannot go and change the
admission plugins that already exist and
in google kubernetes engine we don't let
you build live we don't let you change
the admission plugins that are already
enabled so in this list you're basically
seeing 15 admission plugins that
probably correspond to coordinate these
features that you might be already using
so these are already enabled on GK today
you know the list may mean it may change
tomorrow or in a new version but today
you know in a snapshot it basically
looks like this so I said that admission
plugins are actually compiled into the
kubernetes binary but you can I think as
of kubernetes 1.9 or something like that
you can write your own kubernetes
admission plugins and the way this works
is you know you create a pod and then
pot goes through a bunch of other bunch
of admission plugins and then there is
something called mutating admission
admission webhook and then that calls
your web hook that you might have
registered and in that case you actually
change the API objects that before they
are created so let's say I'm just
trolling people and every time they
create a pod I'm gonna change their pod
name or something like that you can you
can do something like this using the
mutating admission web hooks and the
validating admission web hooks are
basically just if the pot is good or not
so you can write your own admission
plug-in if the pod doesn't look good to
you you can just reject it and the user
with users will see the rejection error
in their QC GL or whatever so this is a
way to extend kubernetes
authorization model if you don't want
something if you don't want someone to
do something on your cluster and if the
authorization is not enough you can use
the admission controls to enforce more
strict policies at your companies by
writing simple web hooks so let's talk a
little bit about the pod security policy
this is a relatively new feature again
this this restricts host access like
host file system host network the ports
do you know the process ID namespace and
stuff like that to the pods
so let's say you want to create a
privileged container this actually
prevents you from setting a policy that
prevents other people from creating
privileged containers so if you hate
privileged containers if you hate
containers running as root this is
exactly what you're looking for in this
diagram I'm looking at a pod spec coming
through the admission coming to the
admission control in the API and then
the admission control particular policy
admission controller checks the pod
security specs that you have and then
based on that it makes a decision again
you know in this example on the Left I
have a pod security policy that this
allows the privilege pods and this
allows the pods running as root user and
on the right on the bottom right I'm
trying to deploy a pod with security
context that has privileged equals true
and this fault will be rejected so next
thing is network policy this is again a
relatively new feature and I think about
six months ago this has gone GA on
Google Currents at Google Koreans engine
so this again defines which pods can
talk to which other pods and this is you
know this can be determined based on
which namespaces the pods live on or
this can be depending on what labels the
pods have or you can specify certain IP
ranges that the pods cannot talk to you
or get traffic from so never policy is
basically firewall written in
community's language for your pots so
we're offering this true calico
networking plugin if you create a
cluster today with - - enable Network
policy you'll be getting that an example
network policy I have here is I'm
selecting a bunch of pods that have the
label F equals my Seco you can see in
the blue and then the next thing I do is
I allow the ingress keyword here means
allow traffic from the pods that have
the labels F equals foreign so in this
case my front end pods talk to the my
circle pods so what I did was I created
a repository for Koreans metric policy
is a while ago at the previous Q con you
can find a link here what I have in this
repository is just bunch of examples of
all the cool things you can do with
never' policy and I really encourage you
to use Koreans Network policy because it
is right
now not utilize a while and it is pretty
good for if you're just looking for non
authorization and simple Network
firewalls so let's jump onto the
scheduling related features the first
one is pod priority and preemption and
the pod priority is it lets you define a
priority that the pods get this is a
numerical value and depending on this
numerical value the pods are scheduled
earlier than the pods with the lower
priority so let's say your cluster is
full and there's a scheduling queue the
high-priority pod goes in front of the
scheduling queue and it gets scheduled
first so if you have a bunch of you know
like space issues in your cluster this
kind of makes sure's as the high
priority pods actually get run first and
the pods preemption again these features
are beta in your going to be beta in
Korea's 111 and the pod preemption if
it's lower priority pods from a node so
let's say your cluster is full you don't
have any more space but someone just
deployed something super important like
the you know the high priority web from
that application it just released any
version and they need to scale up what
happens is that the pod preemption which
will again come in 111 its kind of
evicted lower priority pods from the
cluster and again you know this is
depending on the numerical value in this
example here I have three priority
classes that I created and one of them
is high you know I just assign the value
like 1 million and then there's a normal
it has value of thousand and then there
is a global default true this means that
if I create a priority class like this
this global default true gets applied to
any port created by default and then the
low has value 10 and this is a non
namespace object so when you apply this
to your cluster everyone uses it so if
you have if you come up with certain
priorities at your company this is
something that you can directly utilize
and I'm going to talk about a little bit
about resource coders this is probably
the most important policy object if
you're trying to limit usage in your
companies in a single cluster so
resource quotas are per namespace it
limit it lets you limit the total memory
CPU storage use and you know like the
load balancer use and how
politic new space can have how many
config maps or whatever a namespace can
have for each tenant so here's an
example resource Kota in this resource
Kota I'm deploying these to the staging
namespace and on the Left I'm basically
saying on this namespace you can have
only Tory pods and you can have two
total services you cannot have services
with load balancer type because that
load balancer is a public load balancer
if you know if I know that this team is
not gonna need a public load balancer I
can just disable that and I let this
team use five volley five persistent
volumes these are on GK they're like GC
persistent disks so which is a billable
resource in this case I can kind of
limit the spending of this team and on
the right I have the compute kora of
this team I can say I'm allocating a
scores of CPU or ten cores of CPU if
they if they're burst of all to this
particular tenant and in there as far as
the RAM is concerned I'm allocating
three gigabytes of RAM to the Stennis
and again I have a storage field here
which basically says that the total
volume of the persistent volume claims
cannot go over 120 gigabytes so resource
code is fairly flexible and lets you do
stuff like that so as of kubernetes 111
some features go on alpha and that
feature is we're I think craze is
allowing you to combine resource coders
with priority classes so if you ever you
know wondered or what if like I want to
set five CPUs for my high priority work
clothes that's exactly what you're
looking at so on the top left here I
define a low priority class you know we
define that before and then here I'm
basically creating a path with the
priority class low
that's an unimportant pod and on the
right I'm setting a resource coda in
this namespace based on the priority
class so I'm saying that low priority
class pods can have in total I can have
100 of these pods and they can only use
you know total of 10 CPUs and that's why
you buy some memory so what are they got
most important features you're probably
gonna you know go home and try out is
pod anti affinity so this feature but
basically if you don't want to call okay
tenants on a single node versus a lot of
finance companies there are this
requirement this is kind of what you're
looking for for anti affinity lets you
use constraints such as labels to
prevent scheduling on certain nodes in
this example I have a pod that says
label equals sorry the label has team
equals billing and on the right I have
another pot that is specifying a anti
affinity rule and I'm saying that look
at the kubernetes hostname this is the
node name right and in this node name
don't put me on a node that does not
have the billing like another pot that
has the billing label so this lets you
again flexibly use this clusters anytime
someone you know gets scheduled there
the next thing you do is another part
that comes in basically trust this model
and then it will not get scheduled by
coronaries on the rainy circumstance to
that node another concept that you might
utilize especially if you have different
source of hardware in your data center
is dedicated nodes let's say you have a
mission Learning Team they ordered a
bunch of GP nodes right our they're
already using GP nodes on google
kubernetes engine and in this case you
can reserve these nodes for the machine
learning team and then no one else will
be able to schedule to it and the way
this works is we're using teens and
Toleration feature on Google query
engine so normally what you do is you
run the command QCT i'll paint node and
then specify the node name to put a
taint on the node but in gk case you can
directly apply these tenants to the node
fools so any time the node pool scales
up where the pod gets or a node gets
removed because of auto repair or a
scale down event or something like that
all of the nodes in that node pool will
always have this team equals machine
learning no scheduled tenant so GK
offers you this flexibility to do that
and as far as the Toleration czar
concerned any part that wants to
schedule on this node needs to have this
particular toleration as you see on the
bottom right
that's saying machine learning effect no
schedule and you know the teaming team
equals machine learning I'm gonna use
the effect no schedule so when you use
that your pod gets scheduled onto the
GPU node so again I'm I'm gonna call you
Yoshi to here and he's gonna talk about
sandbox pods and G visor thank you all
my awesome
ah before actually jumping in how many
of you actually came to my G visor talk
which happened like three minutes ago or
okay great um so for those sorry it's
gonna be a little bit of repetition but
if you have any question later it could
definitely talk about so sandbox cause
we I want to talk about a lot of
primitives that we have today in
Carini's and current engines sandbox
pause is something that we're trying to
we are building today and hopefully to
address the fundamental problem around a
continued isolation boundary there are
two approaches right now which we're
gonna talk to you guys but before that
other two one is kata container is one
that will hopefully come you know work
with the sandbox pot API and we have a
gene visor as a runtime for the sandbox
API the concept of sandbox is really
about content making containers really
contain to address the threat that's
coming from inside which we'll talk
right now
first shortly so the divisor this is the
Google approach to the sandbox pause so
divisor is a kind of run you know new
runtime for containers to really make it
contain inside the sandbox today when
you run containers containers will
directly interact with the host Linux
kernel and the system interface there
like Cisco's and slash part of /proc
filesystem you have a very huge huge
attacking surface there and if a
container actually if a malicious
application inside the container
exploits the bugs in the community in
the kernel and then escapes that can
general Dane basically you could you
know and then the privilege discussion
happens then basically your system could
be compromised
now as you can see from this diagram G
visor will sit in the middle and
prevented it by itself is an independent
kernel it implements the leaner system
calls in userspace by saying it what I
mean by that user space is that
container would still think that oh my
sis call system calls are handled
properly but what is actually
interacting with is the system that the
user in the independent kernel that is
running inside the user space so what's
going to happen is that even if the G
visor it's just one other software has a
vulnerability and this malicious
software happened to be able to take
advantage of that and breaks in now
what's going to happen is that basically
that's one it only just broke the one
boundary you still have another boundary
between G visor and kernel another
aspect about G visor is that there are a
lot of tools that will harden Linux and
reduce a system surface such as second
filter and SELinux the challenge there
is that you do need to know what you're
doing for your application and your
users and even if you're able to do so
it doesn't mean that you can use the
policy for every application you have to
mandate that to the application to
follow that guideline or there you can
lower in or you lower the bar so what's
going to happen like
infrequently is that if you try to cover
more application more use cases then you
you know step back step back a little
bit and then you have even much more
less described in policies or rules here
on the other hand and it's definitely
kind of complex actually come up with
that now on the other hand advisor it
does not have any configuration will
look into later but you know from
application standpoint you can bring in
you know basically you know any
application on top of G visor and run on
top and you have to modify it let's
divide yourself is really an angle
language which is the memory and type
space type safe that's much more
stronger language to describe the system
component like the G visor
so you guys are encrypted how it's going
to look like from architecture
perspective divisor is going to provide
a sandbox but on top of that we have run
SC which is the OCI runtime that is
actually powered by G as you visor so
kubernetes will could be talking into
this rana C bio CI or even darker can
talk to run a CI o CI as I mentioned so
underneath it there's your container
will be running inside the sandbox and
you'll see in this case the century a
century the user land kernel of G visor
is wrapping around that container and
then there's another filter which is
second plus name space underneath
century which we called another boundary
so basically one isolation and to
isolation boundary second in first and
second to show how it kind of works when
the cat your container makes a system
call then it will be trapped by the so
we call it con a platform I show KVM
here but we also have P trees the other
syscall will be captured and forwarded
to the user land kernel so this is the
first key instead of implement the Cisco
system call in the colonel colonel in in
kernel it goes back to the user land and
then implement as much as possible there
are cases are they are to implement
Accenture has to call the system call to
implement the request this is call but
we significantly filter the actual
system called the century is going to
make to the Linux kernel and that's
exactly where a second comes into play
and it is surrounded by a namespace it's
around like 10 to 20 air Cisco compared
to the full 300 you know 2000 Cisco
that's exposed in the regular leanness
kernel so it's much more restricted file
i/o and a networking is also another
surface we have to take care of by
default container your container will
not have direct access to the file host
file system everything will be handled
by so-called gopher
which will handle the file and
networking and we have 9p protocol to to
connect over and in the century there
so this is like I mentioned the sandbox
pod incriminate this is exactly what we
are working or leading effort with in
the community it is working progress so
it's not something available yet but I
think we have a very final stage of the
the spec at this moment actually this is
really my third time revising this deck
so what I'm showing now is the latest
one there's no guarantee that's not
gonna change I'm pretty sure that things
will change anyway so just drink it as a
grain of salt and also like unlike all
miss Austin yamo file I'm on p.m. I'm
just going to take advantage of that to
say very simple short arrow file for my
talk so a runtime class is the new API
to specify ROM time so that we can
implement this concept called sandbox
pods the left side of the CML file is
the actual way to specify the rom time
class and you can see the meta name so
this clock this runtime class will be
named G visor and inside there the
runtime handler called G visor inside
this runtime handler you can specify the
actual and executable file and all the
parameters in there but we believe that
this left side of the specifying a
runtime class part will be defined by
the class remnant or in case of cloud
like us you know google kubernetes
engine will be us who will be defining
the runtime class for you and from a
user perspective you only all you have
to do is to specify which runtime which
runtime class you want to use for your
pod so on the right side you can see
this all you have to do just a regular
write your regular pod and then say
runtime class name G visor which is
provided by from your Frey which is
defined by the left hand side so it's
very soon straightfoward already so we
talked about multi-tenancy and all may
talk about you know you know discuss and
i hopefully you know introduce you to
what are the things needed to use
multi-tenancy but there are some areas
that we're still working on and where
the community is still kind of working
on sometimes wanted to go quickly go
through that
polity management I think this is really
perhaps in my my only myself but when
Ahmed was talking about Arabic and
policy any all the Amla files
it is indeed you know you have to know
what you need to do and doing just one
is already complicated enough but when
you're responsible for providing such an
environment for a larger organization
with many many project yes it's not
going to be necessary scalable it is a
challenge to make sure that that I am in
policy is up to date like once you
define it great but how do you know that
is actually still consistent in the long
run and or that like a different
projects routine so that will be the
kind of challenge and I'm very excited
to introduce this Karuna changing policy
management this is very new alpha this
is the product that my colleagues are
working on and unfortunately we have
this kind of a colliding so it's the
talk is now happening Moscow himself
Moscone South so I will strongly
recommend to watch that video I want to
see this get uploaded but I'm just going
to tell you the nutshell because I had a
chance to you know understand the vision
from the T L in the PM's yesterday so
like I mentioned the policy management
and scaling that is very very
challenging so the ideal vision here is
it all you have to do is come to the you
know community you know conch cloud
console and when you specify the project
from your organization folder you know
if you opt in once you create a product
it will automatically create a name
space inside your cluster for you so
like team building or team development
once you do that it will always create a
name set with a particular labeling so
that you don't have to worry about it so
the larger vision is that yes you can
specify a lot of those policy here and
there but isn't it much more effective
and ideal you know developer and user
experience if we could provide a
cohesive kind of view there and that's
what's all about with this curve Anisa
engine policy management so two things
also the talk I owe 200
happening now it's definitely a strong
recommend watching this after once gets
uploaded also this is an alpha they
absolutely want feet and you know
signing or somebody to sign up and also
feedback so please come to this you know
click go through this a sign-up form if
you're interested in scaling your policy
management also Karina's multi-tenancy
has some a lot of some limitation one is
that for now the api calls are not rate
limited so you can see that you know
this is could be a perhaps one of the
tackling surface and we should you know
we we need to address that in the long
run and also networking is also another
kind of schedule resources yet so we do
need to figure out what would be the
right way to kind of slice a networking
resource and attach it to the donor to
the namespace and also tenors can still
discover each other via by the coroner
CNS so these are the kind of a high
level control plane robustness and kind
of a you know isolation we will probably
need if we want to implement the full
kubernetes multi-tenancy which them the
model that almond introduced in earlier
in his flies okay so key takeaway for
the multi-tenancy in general first are
defining it's kind of a - you know it's
a very kind of rule of thumb but I think
is very important determine your use
case is your user coming from outside
your organization or inside your
organization that's one way to look at
it but fur has much more interning how
trusted is you know you know are your
tenon and users and work clothes this is
this actually perhaps more more
important if you trust everyone
correctly and if you trust whatever
software that they're going to varying I
think you have a better in your in a
better position to not to use all the
isolation mechanism or policy
intensively but if not you do you do
need something and related to that was
sort of a degree of you know isolation
that do you want to have is it for the
cluster level
or the caning toleration then I let me
talk about you know it's a new level or
we actually wanted to even split inside
a node and if you're looking for that
yes sandbox spot will be definitely kind
of something I wanted to think about and
the namespace specific multi-tenancy we
do understand as of now the namespace is
still perhaps a newer concept for those
who are already kind of taken you know
using namespace I think you know it's
totally fair to think that namespace is
the kind of starting point to think
about the multi-tenancy in communities
and Cronus engine what I also understand
that for though there are people who are
run actually running multi-tenancy
services so team a team be running a
same cluster but not using namespace um
that's what I find but I definitely do
recommend you know you know using you're
considering namespace are you know
moving forward and here you wanted to
utilize a policy object and scheduling
and access control and also you think
about the persona and how you wanted to
map into the our bag
you know closing rules in there and if
you have you know if you're if you have
more complicated now of course you could
definitely you know the problem is very
complex enough for a single cluster but
if you actually do want to have more
robust and great user experience from
single cluster to multiple cluster this
GK Google query engine during policy
management that's gonna be announced
right and it has been announced now will
be there great choice for your so I
strongly recommend looking into this
okay so that's it I think so almighty
wanted to talk about the call for
actions yeah in this case we want you to
bring your opinions to the multi-tenancy
space so for that you can keep this
slide up for a bit so you can take a
picture of that and go to GK that page
that link slash multi - tenancy and you
know fill up this form to register your
interest what do you want to see what is
your use case we really want to hear
about this and in the open source
community the work is still happening
when we look at the community space here
ago there were only a few of the policy
objects that we were talking about and
now we're
the state where most of the policy
objects are in some of them are already
g8 such as the resource quota and some
of them are going beta and some of them
are coming up very recently as alpha so
we want also do two if you're interested
in this space wants you to participate
in the open source community
so most prominently the relevant working
group in communities space is going to
be the multi-tenancy working group and
in this in this case they this work
group is led by engineers from Google
and Microsoft and you know you can find
their links here to join this work group
similarly the policies are very key to
Granny's multi-tenancy and the careers
policy working group is looking at these
sort of policies but it's about how we
can use the namespace logical boundary
and take it to a place where people can
use it to achieve multi-tenancy in their
clusters again the koreans policy
working group is it's a pretty fun place
to hang out I would totally recommend
reading their design Docs and there are
two other working groups that I have not
listed here one of them is sing-off
which looks at authorization and
authentication if you're interested in
our bag and you know I am and how these
things work and if you want to you know
bring I don't know your own YDC provider
and stuff like that if you want to
provide opinions in that area seek off
is where you should look at again
another one is SIG's scheduling as the
name indicates they bring a lot of stuff
from the policy workgroup and you know
already from it already stuff that
exists in communities such as you know I
talked about how the pods preemption and
pods priorities work this is 66
scheduling so you should definitely
check out the six scheduling as well if
you're generally interested in you know
that distributed systems scheduling
space six scheduling again is a nice
place to hang out and there are a lot of
interesting design Doc's there so this
concludes our talk thanks again for
coming up again you know this link is
still going to be there so if you feel
free to take pictures of that if you
have questions I think we have only a
few minutes but we can you know get
questions at the mic but we'll make
ourselves available here after the talk
as well so please don't hesitate to ask
your questions again thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]